this is a question I've got about
marking I guess like this my teacher
showed me some ways of proving
trigonometric identities that have left
my teaching school divided as to whether
it should receive full marks
they are consider left-hand side /
right-hand side
it showed that left-hand side /
right-hand side equals 1 through
simplification
hence left hand side equals right-hand
side I guess because in theory if you
take this slide and then multiply both
sides by the right hand side you cancel
it over here but if the right hand side
appears over here which is how you get
this which is what you're trying to
prove that's suggestion number one
suggestion number to consider left hand
side - right hand side and show that
left hand side - right hand side equals
0 through simplification and heads
instead of multiplying by right-hand
side you you add the right-hand side to
both sides and that's how you get this
without the here thoughts of whether you
think would be a valid full mark
solution in the extension 1 exam okay
thanks for riding I guess the first
thing I want to say is what about to
give you in my opinion nothing more so
you know it's it's it's not something
that I would use in an argument really
but just in case you're curious this is
what I think my second comment by the
way is um not just that you've got these
two choices here but my definite
preference would be if what you were
required to prove was and then they give
you a statement left hand side equals
the right hand side okay I think the
different preference would be to say
I'll start from one side or the other
and it doesn't matter which one and say
okay well you start with the left hand
side and then you say what it's equal to
and if you can do all of the algebraic
manipulation required to do either of
these proofs then you should be able to
simplify whatever is here ba ba bla bla
bla bla and then eventually get to the
other side from one side to the other
rather than trying to consider sort of
some kind of different situation I think
this is what's preferable and I've
demonstrated that my videos tons of
times
so I think this is the clearest way to
prove it and always the preference but
that's it here is my opinion on these
two methods that you've been
Ida September 2 I think number two sort
of a goer
but I recommend strongly against using
number one that's not to say it's wrong
but I don't think it's a good idea now
the reason why I dislike number 1 is
because division division it here it's a
dangerous thing when it comes to
functions so composite functions
involving division they have
restrictions and let me show you what I
mean
if I were to consider two different
functions let's go so if I considered f
of X let's say that graph there okay and
this is pretty simple it looks like this
okay he's your axes and everyone knows
what y equals x or f of X rather if I
make that the f axis this is the x axis
that's that's what it looks like there
problems okay but if I were to say
consider a similar function something
like this x squared on X simplification
would tell you sorry I should let skip
that different it was ecology
simplification should tell you that
every time you sub in a value you get
the same graph as what you have over
here the simplification should tell you
that algebraically but every value works
except for one namely x equals zero X
can't equal 0 you put it in you get 0/0
and so at the origin there's a hole
there there's a gap and then the rest of
the graph does look the same so these
two functions F and G I know they look
very similar but because of the division
that's been introduced here they're not
the same okay
and you know this problem kind of creeps
up all the time when we're doing you
know T solutions T methods so when you
say let T equals equal tan theta on two
and then you get your result for sine
theta and your result for cars and so on
right when you have n equation two you
solve it in terms of sines and causes
that's fine but when you introduce t you
see tan is a reciprocal sign non
reciprocal it's a it's a it's a ratio
between silent cause so you've
introduced a division of a function
right so if you were using this this
method right you're gonna get holes in
it and that's why you have to test bring
this up a little bit that's why you have
to test other values namely feed equals
PI right because when theta is equal to
PI tenth in or two is undefined even if
the rest of the stuff that was your
original question is defined
so therefore this ID here consider left
hand side divided by right hand side
well yeah you can't be careful with that
right for all intents and purposes with
the trig identities that you get this
will probably still be true but I think
it's a bad idea to introduce division
where it's unnecessary because of things
like things like this introducing these
holes places where the solution doesn't
exist okay now number two this consider
left hand side - - right hand side
that's a much safer option I think in
fact it's used improving inequalities
all the time so if what you were asked
to prove was something like this you're
asked to prove a is greater than B a
very very common thing is to say well
let's consider a - B and then you do
some algebraic manipulation with that
bottle of law until you get something
over this side which you can clearly say
oh look that's positive you know for
instance maybe you you manipulate in
such way to show that it's a square
number and that it can't be equal to
zero either so once you establish this
you see in terms of functions adding and
subtraction are much safer then then
multiplication and division because they
don't introduce any of those
restrictions that I mentioned before so
I think this would definitely be
accepted with full marks like I said
it's all just my opinion but I hope that
makes sense